What would be a practical approach for
developing your shadow?
Well,
that's a good one.
Let's,
let's do a little review of union
psychology.
The first thing is,
if you want to know about this,
the proper sources.
Carl [inaudible] collected works volume
nine,
volume nine,
and there's two parts to volume 9:00
AM be published as separate texts and
volume nine is called archetypes of the
collective unconscious and the other one
is called a ion.
But in archetypes of the collective
unconscious,
there's a good discussion of the persona
and the shadow and the persona you could
say.
Is that a good way of thinking about it?
You know,
you watch all those Rom coms where
there's always kind of a Beta male guy
who's being real friendly and always
failing miserably with women because
basically he's lying to himself and to
them,
um,
he's a persona and a persona is the face
that you show to the world when you're
trying to pretend and to convince
yourself and others that you're,
I would say harmless,
but we could say a good person,
but a good person isn't harmless.
A good person is capable of,
well,
maybe a good person is capable of
anything but is willing to hold that in
abeyance.
I read this interesting commentary a
little while ago on a statement by
Christ in the New Testament and the
statement generally interpreted is that
the meek shall inherit the earth,
but I was looking up the multiple
translations of the word meek.
Meek is actually derived from a Greek
word of course,
because the Bible,
at least some of the original forms of
the Bible were in Greek.
And that word didn't exactly mean meek.
It meant something like,
uh,
those who have weapons and the ability
to use them,
but cert,
but determined to keep the machine will
inherit the world.
And that means that people who are
capable of force,
let's say,
but decide not to use it,
are in the proper moral position.
And meet you commented on that a fair
bit too.
You know,
he,
um,
thought of most moral morality as
cowardice,
not because morality itself was
but because most people who are cowards
disguise their coward,
cowardice as morality,
and they claim that they're
harmlessness,
which is actually a consequence of their
fear and inability to be harmful,
say,
or to be dangerous,
is actually a sign of their moral
integrity.
And that's a really bad idea.
So,
you know,
if you're an ax murderer but you don't
have an ax,
that doesn't mean that your moral.
So now with regards to,
so that's the persona and the persona is
the mask that you wear.
And that's what persona means is the
mask that you wear to convince and the
world that you're not a terrible monster
so that when you look at yourself in the
mirror,
you don't have to run away screaming.
You know,
when you might think,
well that's a bit of an overstatement.
But you'll was very interested in
phenomena such as say,
psychological.
The psychological phenomena that would
characterize the actions of someone who
might be an Auschwitz camp guard for
example.
And uh,
you know,
that's pretty monstrous form of
behavior.
And the thing about Auschwitz camp
guards is that there's no reason to
assume really,
that they were much different than
normal people.
Now,
there would have been exceptions
obviously,
but and what that means is that perhaps
youtube could be an Auschwitz camp guard
and perhaps you would even derive some
enjoyment out of it and you might think
no,
but you shouldn't think not so quickly.
And what that also implies is that if
you could see what that meant when you
looked in the mirror and looked at
yourself,
you might run away screaming because
you'd have a revelation of just exactly
what the human being is capable of.
And that's a very unpleasant revelation.
And also one of the things that stops
people from being enlightened because
that revelation of the evil of the self
is part of the journey to enlightenment
and an early part.
Now the shadow would be all the parts of
the personality that the persona
rejects.
And that might be the aggressive
element.
Certainly the case.
That's the case with for people who are
hyper agreeable,
and now you can tell,
I think one of the best.
There's two pathways to the development
of the shadow and they're tightly
aligned with one another.
Um,
the fundamental pathway is truth,
and that's to face the bitter truth
about yourself,
but to break that down more
particularly,
you might think about that as the
capacity to observe your own resentment.
You're going to be resentful and bitter
in many situations because you don't get
what you want and if you watch that
resentment,
bitterness,
clc,
that it produces fantasies that can be
unbelievably dark and that can be very
frightening and you might not want to
admit to yourself that you're actually
capable of having fantasies like that or
impulses like that or aggressive
feelings like that.
But the thing is is that if those
aggressive feelings and impulses and
fantasies are integrated into your
character,
it's like you're opening up a dialogue
with a part of yourself that can be very
forceful and strong and dangerous and
it's really useful to be dangerous
because if you can,
if you can be dangerous,
you often don't have to be.
And it's often weak.
People,
for example,
it's weak men generally speaking,
who rape.
You know that that's a very,
very common occurrence and that's a
violent act,
but it's born out of weakness,
not out of strength,
that's for sure.
And so anyways,
you attend to your resentment honestly,
and you observe yourself and what you're
actually like.
You got to pay attention as if you don't
know yourself as if you might harbor
hidden devils and then maybe they'll
emerge.
Now,
young also felt that sort of embedded
inside the shot where the contra sexual
tendencies and so for example,
sometimes you see people who are well
men let's say,
and we can.
We can also talk about women in this
regard.
Men who have integrated their shadow
often also develop a kind of peculiar
grace that would be a consequence of not
only allowing their aggressive side to
step forward,
but also their feminine in Compassionate
side that might,
that they may have kept squelched
because of embarrassment about it or
because they'd been harassed for being
weak or any number of things.
So,
but the practical approach for
developing your shadow,
I would say is to contemplate and
consider your resentment and notice what
it says [inaudible] your resentment will
also tell you what you have to say.
You know,
so look,
look at what happened at Google this
weekend.
You know,
James Damore wrote that memo and you can
imagine he was pretty angry and perhaps
even somewhat resentful at having to
attend that diversity seminar.
And I'm really just using this as an
example,
but what he did was decide that that
meant that he had something that he had
to say and then look at the consequences
of that.
Man.
It's an absolutely unbelievable.
And so you know,
if you're feeding oppressed at work or
you're oppressed in your life or,
or you know where you're oppressing
yourself,
then you got to notice that you're
feeling oppressed.
Then you have to notice that you're
feeling resentful,
resentful and angry and bitter,
and maybe even like Cain in the story of
Cain and Abel because cane is sort of
the architectural bitter man.
And then you have to decide what it is
that you need to do in order to remove
from yourself that bitterness.
And that's usually means that there's
something that you have to say and then
you have to say it because you're soul
depends on it.
And not only does your soul depending on
it,
I would say the fate of the world
depends on it because you know you might
be wrong and then you should be
straightened out.
Maybe you're just being whiny and you
have to talk to somebody about that.
But it may be that you're actually
detecting something wrong.
Some tyranny that's directed towards you
and other people.
And it's like your moral obligation to
speak up about it.
And so many workplaces become toxic to
use a terrible cliche because of the
people in the won't speak up for what
they actually want,
or they speak up too late and then
they're all twisted up about it and,
and you know they're torturing other
people because they're so unhappy and so
forth and so on.
So practical approach for developing
your shadow fundamentally is radical.
Honesty and young said that in a genuine
moral effort was a good substitute for
psychotherapy.